non perderti anita stories la serie
animata un nuovo episodio ogni domenica
alle 12 sul mio canale benvenuti sono
già stories pozzi nuova challenge alle 3
di notte lo faremo alle 3 di notte
mangiamo andiamo a fare la challenge tre
colori di pennarelli però con granny
elon able il cioccolato no balti e
jackie o non so se me ne sto
dimenticando colonna evitiamo come ci
escono questi personaggi con i colori
completamente diverso per ogni turno
dovrete votare nel sondaggio chi vince
per ogni turno perché saranno quattro
anni e vitale uscirà ovviamente un
disegno con un colore diverso quindi voi
dovrete votare chi vince per ogni turno
siete pronti
prendete i pop corn e iniziamo subito
alla salle libro di primo turno
sveliamo il nostro primo personaggio il
primo personaggio e nei borghi
ora andiamo a pescare i pennarelli e
vediamo come sia strano con altri colori
e loghi prima sa prendere quattro no
ritorni sono quattro almeno 44 inizia
ancora non sappiamo chi è vero nome
dovuto andare la band car forbice sas ha
cominciato piccoli nati come abbiamo
altri pennarelli quindi non posso
prendere 3 2 1 1 lo devo preparare
oppure lo devo prendere peso che colore
non il male ma non so se li sta bene a
roma quindi non è un colore giallo nero
celeste gambe sì forse qualcosa si possa
fare
no quello no aspettavamo di perdere non
so se ci sta bene con il reg
adesso cos'è
eccolo quello è un po particolare
arancione in si può stare ci può stare
secondo me ci puoi fare niente tutte la
tuta della capacità fisiche saranno
toccate ci sta benissimo questo nostra
offerta e valverde chiaro ma che cavolo
colorare un alieno da me tocca a te ok
io vado che no è marrone ci fa bene se
un modo in cui potresti farlo non te lo
dico non lo so benissimo
vediamo dai rosa non c'entra niente
perché va bene dice qui faremo che
aggiornava posso fare la pelle
altrimenti l'avrei fatto che l'altra
notte nel prossimo al momento questo non
è verde e blu mera che se buio non
stabili sebbene una sorta di blu scuro
horno ok iniziamo subito a correre in
cui viviamo
chi finisce prima o no ma i baffi i
capelli di che colore il falso i capelli
verdi ho paura che si fa stasera
verranno molto visto che gli stiamo
storpiando gli stiamo mettendo questi
colori strani ho paura che sarebbero
allo sacco o che li ho finito io pure
fronti 331 mason gemelli allora io ha
deciso di usare il verde per i capelli
i guanti e le scarpe perché è l'uni per
non si arrabbi che usato il verde per i
capelli
in italia invece più pauroso io ho
utilizzato il marrone per i capelli
quanti i pantaloni un po di scarpe color
carne invece punto per le braccia il
viso e il maglioncino verdino celestino
quindi votate chi vince il primo turno
vice lumines mercati e supercattivo
frati poiché il momento di svelare la
sua secondo personaggio 321 strana paura
paura che credi sarebbe racconta con o
ribelli vivaci
quindici ei perfetto per granny dei
premi ormai rischia di venere amore ho
preso questo che colore è bello non è
bello se per caso si può usare utilizzo
grandi stare benissimo immaginare questo
è perfetto verde oliva capitarvi preso
questa è bello giallo è sì qualcosa
riesco a fare a questo ci sta bene per
davvero vero marroncino questa sì si
possono fare tante cose come la mazza
che umano
ok penso anche di vestigia tema che con
le altre grandi diventerà hurley chi
oggi o'grady sarebbero a posto ho già in
mente qualcosa per 3 2 1
allora io sembro una sirena
io ho deciso di farle la pelle scura il
vestito verde però vedete che il vestito
anche delle sfumature blu poi la massa
blu i capelli blu e gli occhi ecco la
tata tata
chiunque lesività il gran di un po
particolare perché c'è una faccia
arrabbiatissima il colore ma la mia ma
perché celeste scuro e poi agli occhi
gli occhi che sono gialli e blu con gli
occhi storti i denti giallissimi così
come i capelli e la pelle per tre invece
il video non restino purtroppo il
vestitino l'ho dovuto fare da sirena
quindi c'è ancora il colore si regala
quindi sirena volta degli vince il
secondo attore
votate il sondaggio chi vince il mio per
simpatia che siamo al penultimo
personaggio siete pronti 21 e baldi
balti ha così a contro i colori diversi
baldi già abbastanza paura
peschiamo in altri collocamento giro
bene o se apertuta quindi salvi
aiuto aiuto aiuto impressioni quindi per
ora stavolta se ti capita il verde 6
avvantaggiata perché valgono per tutti
che non vi capiterà qualcosa di più
tardi
lo prenderei un po femminile io non ci
potrebbe sta bene ma è presto ma che
come che colori si aspetta che i propri
e colore anzi no ma letizia vale ora
capitaria bang art un po chiaro però ben
attaccate lui è perfetto ugual cronico
la teca rari casi un magistero mi capita
a me adesso è rosa destri altre blue
chips è presto ma guarda che fortunato
ti capita dopo una rosa che voleva pure
sirai a farlo quasi uguale pratica le
solite chiaro bellissimo sai perché
perché ho fatto io a male non male eh i
pantaloni da un bluff di baldi 32 una
premiata
ho chiesto io ho finito a tentativi sono
fatti ci sono così per sempre il solito
i 32
oggi è stranissimo parti con questi
colori
allora il tuo sembra un marziano perché
viola effettivamente e alla stessa così
torna perché gli è successo alla bocca
al tuo e gli ho messo il rossetto il
peggio belle labbra super rosso e buddy
allora il mio l'ho fatto con la maglia
marroncina in pantaloni blu il righello
lo stesso marroncino gli occhi blu
vediamo meglio e alieno faccia rosa con
gli occhi verdi e tanto l'assetto viola
peroni arrichiello viola e scarpe verdi
né allora votate stagionali carabinieri
o servizio di tale questo terzo tour
ora passiamo all'ultimo turno state un
bel mi piace e se questo video raggiunge
i 20 mila mi piace faremo la seconda
parte con nuovi personaggi scrivetemi
pure i movimenti che altri personaggi
volete che colori a pronti a strillare
l'ultimo personaggio affitti sarai tu
questo qui no
ciao ti aiuto oggi e inquietanti
comandata pazza è il più inquietante di
tutti e sarà anche più complicato da
colorare guardate quanti dettagli
quando me sei round sta cosa li mettiamo
colori troppo le armi già sasso questa
volta comincia il rinnovo di petali di
better l'inter allora vediamo per ciechi
che sia il colore ci vogliono ci
vorrebbe un bel ma attenzione perché
belli signor arancione poi ci vorrebbe
un blu per la salopette che colore che
fortuna guarda l'arancione è chiaro sono
molto fortunato che non fanno bene
google sta ci sta benissimo perché
speriamo la mia città fuori lei lille si
potrebbe nuova rosa non è una e lilla e
rosa vedrete che rosa gambe ma dai forse
qualcosina volo ci può stare se la
faccia gialla certi ultimo colore
allarme giusta
maroni per errore si ci sta ci sta
oddio adesso non so di che colore la
salopette ma vabbè dai questo è un altro
no non ce la metterò tutta
[Applauso]
garantita la faccia rosa
ok fatto di 321 al dio favori secondo me
sono pochi tre colori con questo disegno
però è vero dichiara il mio l'ho fatto
biondo perché aveva appunto il giallo
poi ho fatto la felpa gialla ho messo
qualche ricetta arancione la salopette
viola le scarpe gialle il coltello ho
lasciato bianco poi alle labbra viola e
gli occhi viola che sono secondo me la
cosa più inquieta mamma mia è fatto vivo
ecco il mio il mio ai capelli rossicci
marroncini margini rossi psi siccome gli
occhi e la bocca il coltello anche ha
tra l'altro ho fatto il maglioncino rosa
un po più il brigantino sembrano le
braccia non sapevo come colore e poi la
salopette marrone così come le scarpe
chiede chiede che i votate votate nel
sondaggio le vince per ciechi noi
scopriremo chi ha vinto questa challenge
in base ai vostri porti via quando
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere il continuo con altri personaggi
e ora vi lasciamo qua 4 caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite ma fate
piano per non svegliare acciacchi e
buona visione